有天晚上我跟妻子在外面散步，那天的星空很美也很漂亮。
然后我的妻子就问我，说你一个科学爱好者，头顶的星空在你的眼里是不是跟在我的眼里不太一样，是不是太理性他就没有美感了呢？
我说还真的正相反。
可能星空在普通人眼里只是一幅美丽的话，
但对于那些对他稍有了解的人来说，每一束星光背后都有无穷多的故事。
当我们看一束来自45亿光年之外的星光，
我们看到的就是这颗星球45亿年之前的样子。
如果那颗星球上恰好有外星人，
换作他们此时此刻看到的地球还是一个刚刚形成的岩浆球，
上面甚至还没有生命呢？
光是知道人类怎么搞清楚这些星星和我们的位置关系，
怎样绘制出一张以亿万光年为单位的壮美的立体星图，
这么样一个过程，我们这群人眼里的星空就很不一样。
那天我跟妻子聊了挺多，也很感谢她愿意听我说这些在很多人听起来有点无聊的事情。
所以今天这期认真准备的长节目呢，也算是为我妻子做的一次补充吧。
那今天这期我想聊一个听起来很简单，
但其实越想越复杂的问题，
就是我们人类是怎么知道自己在哪里的。
这不仅包括我们要知道自己在大地上的位置，
我们也要聊聊怎样知道自己在宇宙中的位置，
怎么知道那些非常遥远的星星，
它到底有多远？
如果你看过那些表现宇宙空间的视频非常的壮美，
那里面还经常可以俯瞰整个银河系，
还有一个小标识点出我们所在的位置。
其实这些画面都是根据已经被天文学家算出来的数据给推算合成出来的。
实际上也不可能有一个摄像机在银河系外面拍摄银河系，
然后把视频给我们传过来，还能看到我们的位置，
这是不可能的对吧。
人类在地球上能看到的就是身边的山川河流，
以及头顶的一大堆小亮点。
即便到了科技这么发达的今天，
我们看到的其实还是这一堆小亮点，
只是分辨率高了一些，信息更加丰富了一些。
听完我们这期节目你就知道，
要搞清楚我们自己和星星之间的位置，
这件事比我们想的要复杂的多。
人类一步一步走到今天，
为了回答这些问题，
想出了无数多的聪明的点子，
也积累下来无数多的宝贵的智力财富。
时间有的是，我们慢慢聊。
首先，要说我们自己在哪儿，
你可能会觉得这个还挺简单的对吧。
我们拿出手机，打开地图，
马上就能看到一个蓝色的小箭头。
它告诉你你现在在哪一条路上，
离目的地还有多远，
应该往哪个方向走。
但是要想清楚这些问题，
我们就要先把这些现代的工具全部拿掉。
而且这不是一个思想实验，
在真实的世界中，
人类在绝大多数的历史里，
确实就没有我们现在手里的各种尖端的设备。
没有手机，没有卫星，
没有全球统一的坐标，
甚至都没有一张准确的世界地图。
我们只能看见周围的大地和山川，
那那个时候的人又是怎么知道自己在哪里的呢？
再进一步，
如果你是一艘船上的水手，
比如说大地和山川了，
四周全都是海，
看上去一模一样，
没有任何的地标，
你又是怎么知道自己在地球的哪个位置呢？
如果你是之前的一位天文学家，
你看到天上有太阳，
有月亮，
还有数不清的恒星，
但是你又不可能飞过去拿尺子凉，
你怎么知道太阳离我们有多远，
一颗恒星有多远，
一个星系又有多远呢？
所以,
这一期我们定的主题就是。
从大地到星空，
我们人类如何脏凉是尽。
这里面我整理了一条很清楚的推进线，
我们先凉地球的大小，
再定位我们在地球表面的位置，
然后我们要脏凉太阳系，
再凉恒星，再凉星系，
最后我们要凉整个的宇宙。
每一次尺度变大，
人类都需要发明新的方法，
这里面真的有太多人类的智慧了。
所以这一期我会把这些方法。
叫做脏凉世界的尺子，
在我每次介绍一把新的尺子的时候，
你也可以跟着我们的故事。
抛开全知的上帝视角，
我们一起回到历史的当时，
来想想办法，
如果你活在那个时候，
你有没有解决那个问题的思路呢？
那我们就先从最前面，
也最简单的开始，
在没有现代科技的时代，
人们怎么知道地球有多大？
这件事要从一个影子讲起。
我们先回到2000多年前，
那个时候是古希腊时代，
埃及的亚里山大岗。
是地主海世界非常重要的学术中心，
亚里山大图书馆就在这里，
那里有一个学者叫埃拉托斯特尼，
他做过图书馆的馆长，
研究地理和数学。
我们聊他，
是因为他做了一件很厉害的事情，
在没有现代仪器，
没有卫星，
也没有全球地图的情况下，
他估算出了地球的周长。
我们先来想一想，
如果你想知道地球有多大，
最直接的办法是什么呢？
当然就是沿着地球走一圈，
把它粮出来，对吧？
但是这个在古代几乎不可能，
人很难真的沿一条大圆的线路，
绕地球一圈，
就算有人走了很远，
这个路程也很难精确的记录，
即便到了现在，
这也几乎不可能，
如果我们不是生活在城市，
你甚至很难在荒野中沿着一个方向一直向前走，
走着走着就会拐弯。
所以,
埃斯托拉特尼用的是几何推算？
他的观察来自于两个地点，
一个是亚里山大岗，
一个是塞伊尼，
也就是今天埃及的阿斯汪附近，
相传在塞伊尼，
下至这一天的正午，
太阳几乎可以直射到井底，
把井底都照亮，
阳光照进井里，
井壁是没有明显的影子的，
地面上树植的物体影子也非常的短，
这个就说明，
那个时刻，
太阳几乎就在塞伊尼的正头顶，
但是就在同一天，
同一个时刻，
在更北边的亚里山大岗，
情况就不一样，
你在那里树一根柱子，
这个柱子就会投下一段有长度的影子，
这件事看起来挺普通的，
但是,
埃拉托斯特尼就抓住了里面的几何关系，
我们来做个假设，
如果地球它不是圆的，
它是平的，
因为太阳离我们非常远，
阳光可以近似的看成平行光，
那同一时刻照到两个城市，
角度就应该一样，
塞伊尼没有影子，
亚里山大岗应该也没有影子，
但现实是，
一边接近没有影子，
而另外一边有影子，
这就说明，
这两个地方的数值方向不一样，
在球形的地球上，
所谓的数值方向，
其实就是指向地球的中心，
如果地面是弯曲的，
两地的数值方向，
就会存在一个佳角，
这个佳角就是两个城市在地面上。
对应的地心角，
埃拉托斯特尼要做的，
就是测出这个地心角的角度，
那一说这个，
你肯定要回到上地视角了，
头脑中浮现出一个地球，
两个城市和地心之间，
连两条线，
有一个佳角，
我们把这个角量出来就行了，
还是行一行，
没有一个上地视角，
给你一个大大的地球，
让你随便去量，
我们只能在系统的内部，
去测量系统，
那不卖关子了，
怎么测呢？
在亚里山大岗，
下至的正午，
另一根垂直的竿子，
测量竿子的高度，
和影子的长度，
那么太阳光，
竿子和影子，
就构成了一个直角三角形，
稍微学过一点几何学的小伙伴，
就能知道，
我们过程不说了，
但结果，
我们肯定能测出，
阳光,
相对于竖直方向，
偏了多少，
这个角度大约是7.2度，
那7.2度听起来不大，
但是这个意义很大，
一个完整的原周是360度，
360度除以7.2，
等于50,
也就是说，
亚里山大岗，
和塞伊尼之间的距离，
大约对应整个地球原周的50分之一，
那接下来就简单了，
我们要知道，
两地的距离，
再乘以50，
就知道地球的周长了，
说实话，
这个测量有不少的现实的误差，
两地的距离，
也是来自相对的形成，
它不够精确，
你不可能真的拉一把尺子，
两个城市，
也并不严格的，
在同一条经线上，
塞伊尼也不刚好在北回归线上，
等等等等，
但是这些误差，
不影响这个方法的聪明之处，
埃拉托斯特尼真正厉害的地方，
是它建立了一个正确的几何关系，
局部的影子角度，
可以对应到整个地球的原周，
这个就是科学思维非常典型的一种方式，
你不需要把整个地球走完，
你只需要找到一个，
可以被测量的局部的现象，
然后我们把它放到一个合理的模型里，
这里局部的现象就是影子，
模型就是球形地球加平行的阳光，
工具就是角度和比例，
最后一个地球尺度的问题，
就被转化成了一个几何问题，
这件事对当时的人类来说非常重要，
它说明，
地球可以被人类测量，
可以被我们建模，
也可以用数学描述，
影子是一个每个人都建过的东西，
而大多数人看到影子，
只会知道太阳在哪边，
而埃拉托斯特尼看到的影子，
却能想到地球的曲律，
想到地心脚，
想到整个地球的周长，
你看同一个现象，
关键就是我们能不能提出更深的问题，
好，这就是我们说的第一把尺子，
知道地球有多大，只是第一步，
如果我在这颗地球上移动，
尤其是在海上，
四周全是水，
我们怎么知道自己的位置呢？
这就需要第二把尺子，
你可能想不到，
这把尺子它是一块儿中，
我们今天看地图会觉得，
经纬度是很自然的东西，
横数两套线，
把地球表面分成网格，
纬度表示南北，
经度表示东西，
但是在历史上，
经度和纬度的难度，
完全不在一个量级，
纬度很早就有办法测，
纬度就是地球衣上横着的，
把地球切成一片一片的横着的线条，
它之所以好测，
因为纬度和我们看到的天体，
高度直接相关，
你在北半球，
就可以看北极星，
你在吃到附近，
北极星就会贴着地面走，
你越往北走，
它就越高，
到了北极，
它就几乎在头顶，
所以通过北极星的高度，
大致就可以知道你的纬度，
看不到北极星，
也可以测量正午太阳的高度，
结合现在的日期来推算，
像什么像线一样，
六分一样，
这些仪器，
至少都是在测量天体，
和地平线之间的佳角，
只要知道这个佳角的大小，
就能知道你所在的伪度了，
但是,
精度就完全不一样，
精度就是，
从南极连到北极，
这一条一条，
把地球这个大西瓜，
切成一块一块的那个线条，
你在地球上往东走，
或者往西走，
就是改变自己的精度作标，
而这个时候，
星空并不会给你一个直观的高度变化，
还是再次强调，
没有上地视角，
那我们在这个系统内，
是怎么知道自己的精度呢？
这里面真正的核心，
不是位置，
其实是时间，
为什么呢？
因为地球在自转，
大约是24小时转一圈嘛，
360度除以24个小时，
每个小时，
就是转15度，
这个自转的方向，
就是精度改变的方向，
也就是说，
如果两个地方的本地时间，
相差一小时，
那精度大概就差15度，
咱们举个例子啊，
比如你在海上，
观察到太阳达到一天中最高的位置，
这就是你所在的地方的正午，
那与此同时，
如果你知道格林尼治，
现在是下午两点，
那就说明你的本地时间，
比格林尼治要早了两个小时，
东方比西方，
会更早两个小时迎来正午，
所以你在格林尼治以东，
两个小时乘以15度，
就是大约在东京30度附近，
所以精度的计算核心就这一句话，
比较当地的时间，
和基准地点的时间，
那今天我们经常约定俗成的。
这个基准地点的时间，
就是格林尼治的时间，
那我们所在地的时间，
很好测，
我们没有表都可以知道，
就是通过太阳测出来，
太阳最高的时候，
就是正午，
那难点在于，
你在大西洋上，
你怎么知道此刻，
格林尼治是几点呢？
哎，那最直接的办法，
就是带一块中表，对不对？
出发的时候，
我们调成格林尼治时间，
让它在整个航行中，
一直准确地御行，
不就行了吗？
这个听起来很简单，
但是在17和18世纪，
这件事非常的难，
你想一下，
海船上的环境，
船一直在摇晃，
空气很潮湿，
温度变化很大，
还有沿份腐蚀金属，
零件磨损，
热火油变质等等问题，
而中表在当时，
是非常精密的机械系统，
一点点摩擦的变化，
温度的变化，
或者是摆动的干扰，
都会影响走势的准确，
你可能觉得，
比如说每天误差几秒，
这个不算什么，
但是,
精度计算，
对时间是非常敏感的，
地球每四分钟，
转一度，
在赤道上，
一度精度大约就对应。
111公里,
如果时间积累好几天，
从几秒误差到了4分钟，
位置就可能偏100多公里，
航行几周，几个月，
累积下来的误差，
就会非常危险，
这个是真实的危险，
因为它是一个生死的问题，
那个时候出海的人们，
可能以为自己还在安全的海域，
其实已经靠近礁石了，
以为快到港口了，
其实早就错过了，
历史上，
因为精度不准，
造成过很多严重的海难，
所以,
精度测量问题，
在大航海时代，
是国家籍的难题，
英国在1714年通过了精度法案，
设立了精度角，
主要就是悬赏，
悬赏能在远牙行星中，
准确测量精度的方法，
当时有两条技术路线，
一条叫天文路线，
就是越剧法，
越量的越，
距离的剧，
这个方法的原理就是，
越量相对于恒星背景的位置，
会随着时间变化，
精确测量出，
越量和某颗行星的角距离，
我们再查天文表，
就能反推隔离移植时间，
这个方法的好处是，
不依赖一块长期稳定的钟，
但是操作非常复杂，
需要精确的侧角，
查表做大量的计算，
在风浪中的船上，
普通的水手很难完成这样的工作，
第二条路线就是中表路线，
我们造一台足够准确，
足够稳定，
能带上海船的时钟，
看一眼就知道我们现在的精度了，
这里面约翰哈里森，
是这条路线非常重要的人物，
它的背景很有意思，
它甚至不是科学家出身，
是一个木匠出身，
自学钟表制造，
它解决问题的方法，
也非常的工程化，
它不是说，
我们先写一套宏大的理论，
而是具体看机器哪里会出问题，
哪里有问题，
我就改哪里，
一点一点的改，
比如说，
钟摆在海上不好用，
因为这个钟摆需要稳定的中立方向，
这个船翼摇晃，
它就会乱，
所以航海中不能依赖传统的钟摆，
再比如温度变化，
会让零件膨胀收缩，
改变震动的周期，
那它就设计温度补偿机制，
用不同金属膨胀不同的特点，
互相抵消，
摩擦让走石不稳，
它就换材料改结构，
甚至设计减少瑞华依赖的机构，
等等等等吧，
总之呢，
它就是这样，
一点一点的，
用工程化的思想往前改进，
先后造了几台著名的航海钟，
H1像是一台庞大的机械装置，
H2、H3不断的改进，
到了H4,
外形已经接近一块大怀表，
体积小了很多，
精度却非常的高，
你看它这种思想就非常接近。
我们现代发布软件的方式，
我们先搞一个能用的MVP，
然后一点一点的往前叠带，
当然真实的历史，
比这个要复杂的多，
哈里斯和精度委员会争议了很多年，
它的成果也经历了测试，
质疑再测试，
但是从技术角度来看，
航海中确实是非常关键的突破，
它说明，
人类可以把一个基准地点的时间，
给带到大洋上，
我们把逻辑再来梳理一下，
地球自转导致不同精度的本地时间不同，
一小时的时差，
对应大概是15度的精度变化，
在海上用太阳，
确定当地的政务，
然后用船上的时钟，
告诉你格林尼治的标准时间，
时间差换算成角度差，
那就是精度差，
所以航海中表面上在计时，
它实际上是在定位，
它是把时间差换成了空间差，
这个想象还挺有意思的，
实际上这一点很重要，
因为我们现代的导航也延续了同样的思想，
不像很多同学想象的，
GPS并不是卫星在天上看我们，
它主要是靠不同卫星和你的手机之间，
信号传播的时间差来测距离，
这个我们后面还会展开说，
总之卫星用原子钟和无线电，
哈里森用机械钟和太阳观测，
技术不同，
但是底层逻辑是同一句话，
我们也想要知道自己在哪里，
常常先要知道准确的时间，
好，那第二把尺子我们又聊完了，
这个中表主要解决的是，
海上东西的方向定位，
那么回到陆地上，
我们还有一个问题没有解决，
一座山，
一条河，
一座城市，
甚至就是想到你家的房子，
它是怎么被准确的放到地图上的，
这个我们就要聊到第三把尺子，
假设我现在告诉你一个坐标，
北伟31度，东京121度，
那么今天你打开地图软件，
输入经纬度就能看到位置，
可是,
如果我们把手机，卫星，
什么电子地图都拿掉，
问一个更加基础的问题，
这些坐标最早是怎么对应到真实的地面上的，
因为一定在真实的地面先有这些坐标，
才有描述这些坐标的电子地图的，
比如说，我现在告诉你，
我要在东京116.75度，
北伟39.95度，
盖一个房子，
那你作为一个承包商，
怎么能去找到这个位置呢？
要知道，
经纬度本身它只是数字，
你走到野外，
地上不会写着一行字，
这是北伟多少度，对吧？
我们人来要做的是把真实世界里的山川，
道路，城市，海岸线等等，
全都放进一个统一的坐标系统，
这个工作非常的了不起，
它叫做大地测量，
在卫星出现之前，
它最核心的方法，
就是最朴素的三角测量法，
三角测量的基本逻辑不复杂啊，
我一说你就能理解，
如果你知道一个三角形的一条边有多长，
再知道这条边两端的两个角，
那这个三角形就被完全的确定了，
比如有A和B两个点，
我们先把他们之间的距离非常准确的量出来，
这条线就叫做极限，
然后我们想知道远处有一座山，
山顶C点的位置，
我们不需要爬到C点，
实际上我们爬过去也没有用啊，
我们只要站在A点，
用遗弃瞄准C测量一个角度，
然后再站在B点瞄准C测量一个角度，
因为三角形的内角合适180度，
第三个角也就知道了，
用正弦定理就能算出。
AC和BC这两条线的长度，
这个原理最厉害的地方就在于，
你不需要一段一段的走过去两距离，
你完全可以通过光的传播，
通过角度的推算，
算出远处点的位置，
具体的三角函数我们就不展开说了，
这个道理你应该能理解，
它说起来并不复杂，
但其实在真实的世界里，
实操起来是非常非常的难的，
首先第一个问题，
无论后面的那些点怎么算出来，
最初我们得有A和B两个点，
这两个点的坐标，
是从哪里来的呢？
这个是非常重要的问题，
大地坐标它还真的不是。
平空编出来的，
它依托的是天文观测，
来确定出示原点，
这个是在真实世界发生的事啊，
那么我们说，
任何一个坐标系，
它都必须有一个原点，对不对？
这个原点并不是全球统一，
有一个国家制定的，
每个国家都有自己的原点，
一个国家或者一个区域的。
三角测量网，
不会说随便选两个A，B点就开始测，
而是要先划定一个国家。
大地的原点，
大地的基准点，
怎么选这个点呢？
以前可没有GPS导航，
通常会在国土的大概中心位置，
选一个非常稳固的点位，
然后用高精度的天文观测，
测出这个点精确的经纬度，
还有正北的方向，
也就是天文方位角，
精度和纬度怎么知道呢？
我们前面已经讲了，
纬度就是观测北极星，
或者观测特定的恒星的地平高度，
精度就要结合精密的航海中。
或者天文中，
我们选出来的这个点，
知道它精确的经纬度坐标，
这个点就是整个测会体系的总基准，
它的坐标是通过天文实测出来的绝对坐标，
这种地标可不是说，
只在地图里画一下，
而是在真实的物理世界里，
也存放着，
我们中国的大地原点，
在陕西的静养，
那里是一整块，
下面打了13米的水泥桩，
到基岩上，
整块岩石被放在地下室里，
避免被岁月所侵蚀，
这块大石头上就写着，
中华人民共和国大地原点，
有了这个原点之后，
接下来我们就要从它开始，
引出第一条极限，
也就是AB两个点，
我们在大地原点周边，
比较平坦的地方，
布设A和B两个点，
还是先通过天文观测，
测出A点的绝对经纬度，
然后人工测量，
得到AB之间的精确距离，
再用天文观测，
测出AB这条极限的方位角，
也就是它的朝向，
那么到这里，
A点的坐标就已知了，
AB的长度已知了，
AB的方向也已知了，
那B点的坐标，
就不用天文观测了，
就可以直接通过几何学给它算出来了，
那么到这一步，
加上它们的间距全都落地，
三角网的起点，
就算正式成立了，
不过还要说一下，
刚才咱们简简单的一句话，
测量AB两点之间的距离，
这个实操起来也是非常难的，
那首先你的极限就必须测得特别准，
人类早期是用测量链，
用两杆，
后来是用阴瓦尺，
只是一种热膨胀系数很小的合金，
因为普通金属会热胀冷缩，
两几公里的时候，
三角网插就很大了，
极限要反复的测，
做温度的修正，
把鞋距换成水平距离，
非常的麻烦，而且还不能偷懒，
因为这一步一旦有误差，
后面整张坐标网都会跟着测，
因为所有的三角形都是从这条基准线推开的嘛，
那么接下来就是选三角点，
我们要选视野开阔，
能互相看见的位置，
比如说山顶啊，
塔楼啊，
叫堂的坚定啊，
这样需要通视，中间不能被山或者树林挡住，
所以测量员要真的到现场去，
爬到山顶架设仪器，
用望远镜瞄准另外一处山头上的信标，
我在上大学读书的时候，
就经常扛着很重的仪器，
去山里面搞测量，
不知道你有没有见过那种，
扛着一个不知名的黄颜色的仪器，
下面有一个三角架，
然后那个人在那一边瞄远出，
一边做记录，
他们是在做大地的测量，
注意我们用这种仪器量的都是角度，
而不能直接测距离，
那两脚最典型的仪器就是金尾仪，
它名字听起来像是测金尾度的，
实际上它的核心功能就是测角度，
水平脚和垂直脚都能测，
那么最后，
我们就是把三角形扩展成一张网，
通过ab算出c点，
c点确定之后又变成新的一支点，
再用三角形去推d点，1.f点等等等等，
一个接一个，逐渐形成，
覆盖越来越大区域的三角网，
这些控制点就像是地图的骨架，
有了这些骨架，
再去测核流，道路，村庄，
地图才不会越画越歪，
这套逻辑到今天也没有消失，
现代测货里仍然有控制点，
控制网的概念，
只是说我们把仪器换成了。
更高精度的全站仪，
跟ss还有激光雷达等等，
这些三角网中的节点，
不是想象出来的，
同样在真实世界中，
它们是有物理标地物的，
有的是用混凝土或者花钢岩。
做的巨大的敦子，
埋身几米非常的重，
也有的是十几米高的钢三角架。
搭出来的标识点，
我们在城市的道路上，
也经常能看见一些圆形的金属片，
埋在这个人形道，
埋在桥敦或者是基石上，
上面刻着一些编号，
如果你走到那种比较老的步行街，
一般都会在石头的焦点，
看到这样的小圆片，
这种东西旁边一般都会写上。
国家水准点，
严禁搬运这样的字样，
这些点都是受到法律保护的，
不能碰也不能砸，
更不能在上面盖房子，
这都是违法的，
不过这里还有问题，
我们刚才默认地面是平的，
侧这个三角形，
但如果我们侧一个省，
侧一个国家，
就必须考虑地球的曲率，
更麻烦的是，
地球它还不是一个完美的球体，
它其实更接近一个旋转的妥球体，
赤道方向会鼓一点，
两极方向会扁一点，
这个和自转有关，
所以，要给地球上每个点。
分配经纬度，
得先约定一个数学模型，
我们到底把地球看成什么形状，
这个就是参考妥球，
再加上，
高度从哪个基准面算起，
本书子五线定义在哪里，
坐标语言点和方向怎么定，
这一整套约定合起来，
就叫坐标参考系统，
或者大地基准，
实操起来那是非常的复杂，
远远不是咱们普通人能参与的，
我们今天常听到的WGS84，
就是全球卫星导航。
经常用的一套
坐标参考系统，
但是要注意，
它是第一正确的一套，
历史上不同国家都有自己的基准，
所以同一个地点，
在不同的坐标系统下，
经纬度都会有差别，
并不是说地面动了，
是参考框架变了，
所以坐标永远要回答，
它是相对于哪一套参考系统的，
只不过现在世界走到了全球化，
大家约定一套共同使用的系统，
就像我们要约定一套。
共同使用的日期系统一样，
也只有这样，
GPS导航系统才能跑得起来，
既然说到这，
我就干脆把GPS的远离。
给你讲清楚吧，
我们今天有了卫星，
但是真的不是大家想象那样，
天上有很多只眼睛，
往地球上一看，
就知道每个人在哪，他看不见，
简单来说，
GPS的远离，
是你的手机在同时。
接收多颗卫星的信号，
每颗卫星都告诉你两件事，
我就是那个卫星，
我在哪里，
我发出信号的时间，
是几点几分几秒，
信号是以光速传播，
传播的时间乘以光速，
那就是距离了，
一颗卫星通过计算，
信号传到你的手机，
再返回去这个往返的时间，
就能把你限定在一个球面上，
但他不能知道你准确的位置，
为什么是一个球面呢，
因为在空间里面，
所有的点的集合就是球面，
说本来就是因为，
第一颗卫星只能知道你离它的。
距离有多远，但是不知道具体位置，
但没有关系，
我们用两颗不同位置的卫星，
给你发信号，计算距离，
那么就能把你锁定在两个球面上，
这两个球面相交，
就能锁脚范围了，
三颗卫星计算距离，
就可以确定你空间的位置了，
就是你在空间里，
画三个相交的球面，
同时相交只能在一个确定的点，
那个点就是你的位置，
再来第四颗就是修正你设备的。
时钟误差，
所以GPS的原理，
它依然是一个集合问题，
不是一个上帝视角，
只不过三角形从地面的三角网，
变成了你和卫星之间的空间关系，
这也解释了，
为什么我们在高楼，
在密林，在峡谷之间，
定位会变差，
甚至定位会出现几十米的偏差，
那有这个偏差，并不是说，
卫星看不见你了，
而是说，计算的信号数据被打乱了，
更具体来说就是，
卫星计算你和它之间的距离出现了误差，
比如信号先打到玻璃墓墙，
再进入你的手机，
手机以为这个光走的是直线，
那距离就算错了，
距离算错了，位置也就算错了，
好，那么，
从一条机线到一张三角网，
从山顶的经纬仪，
到天上的卫星，
到天上的事情就是这样的，
我们人类把真实世界里的位置关系，
翻译成了数学关系，
那么到此，
我们就把地表的事都凉完了，
我们人类肯定是不会满足的，
下一步，我们自然就会抬头问下一个问题，
那个很亮的太阳，
到底离我们有多远呢？
接下来，
我们就要请出下一把尺子，
这把尺子就是，
我们的地球本身，
太阳有多远，
因为今天看起来不算很难，
我们的日地平均距离。
大概是1.5亿公里，
也叫做一个天文单位，
但是你在古代或者是近代的早期，
这个问题都非常的难，
因为太阳和山
和城市都不一样，
我们首先不可能走过去，不能拉尺子，
也不能派人去太阳旁边做标记，
更麻烦的是，
光凭眼睛看，
天文的距离是很难判断的，
我们平时觉得东西。
看起来大，它就是近，
看起来小，它就是远，
但是天文学就不是这样的，
太阳在天空中看起来，
它的绝对大小和月亮是差不多大的，
这完全不说明他们差不多远，对吧？
事实上，
太阳比月亮大的多，也远得多，
这两个因素刚好在视觉角度上抵消了，
所以请你记住这句话，
在后面也很有用，
这句话是，
在天文学上并不是月亮的东西，
越近，越远的东西越暗，
一个东西看起来比另外一个东西亮，
有可能是它本身特别的亮，
也有可能是它离我们更近，
同样，一个东西的大小。
也不能作为距离我们远近的判断，
那么,
只看大小和亮度不够，
怎么办呢？
我们聪明的人类还是要回到几何学，
还是要用三角形，
古希腊有一个人叫阿里斯塔克，
他提出过一种方法，
他说,
当月亮正好是半月的时候，
月亮被照亮的那一半。
正对着太阳，
那么地球，月亮和太阳之间，
就会形成一个近似的直角三角形，
这个时候，精确的测量出。
太阳和月亮在天空中的。
加角，就能推算出。
两者距离的比例，
这个思路是对的，
但是那个角度，你只能说是。
非常接近九十度，
但其实在天文学中，
角度稍微偏一点点，
结果就会差很多，
数字并不可靠，
后来真正推动太阳系。
尺度测量的经典方法，
叫做视差法，视觉的是，
相差的差，
视差这个概念，
我们后面讲恒星的距离的时候，
还会用到，我们在这先把它讲清楚，
你现在可以伸出一根手指，
放在你的眼前，
先闭上左眼，只用右眼看，
然后一瞬间，再切换到。
闭上右眼，用左眼看，
你会发现，手指头相对于。
伸出背景的位置，
会有一个移动，
你的手指是没有动的，
只是因为你两只眼睛的位置不一样，
所以视线的方向，
也就是这个夹角会略有不同，
这个就是视差，
你可以再把手指头，
离你的眼睛近一些，
或者远一些观察一下，
离你越近的东西，
这个视差就越大，
离你越远的东西，
视差就会越小，
就算出一个东西，
距离我们多远的，
只不过我们自己没有意识到。
有这个计算的过程，
这也是为什么当你闭上一只眼睛，
就比较难判断一个东西，
离你远还是近了，
我们可以利用这个原理，
把两个观测点，
比做我们的两只眼睛，
只要知道两个观测点之间的距离，
也就是极限的长度，
再知道目标偏移了多少角度，
也就是视差，
我们就能用三角形的几何原理，
算出距离了，
测量太阳系的时候，
极限就是地球上两个相距很远的地点，
我们选的第一个观测点是在欧洲，
另外一个是在南太平洋，
两个人在同一个时刻，
看到同一个天象，
角度会有细微的差异，
差异很小，
但是只要测得够准，
就能推算出距离，
那么这个天象是什么呢，
最经典的例子就是。
金星灵日，
金星运行到地球和太阳之间的时候，
从地球上看，
它像一个小黑点，
从太阳圆盘前面慢慢的爬过去，
这个现象并不常见，
相邻两次可能隔很多年，
所以历史上每一次金星灵日都非常的珍贵，
为什么它可以帮助人类测太阳的距离呢？
因为地球上不同位置的观测者，
看到金星走过太阳表面的路径，
会稍微有点不同，
北边的人看它，
会从偏上的位置经过太阳，
南边的人看它，
会从偏下的位置经过太阳，
那就像我们放在眼睛前面的手指头一样，
金星的位置没变，
是观测的位置变了，
这个就是视差，
只要我们准确的记录，
金星进入和离开太阳圆盘的时刻，
比较不同地点的差异，
再结合两地的距离，
就能推算出金星离地球有多远，
这里你肯定会觉得有点奇怪，
我们通过视差法量出来的是，
我们到金星的距离，
而并不知道我们距离那个参照背景，
也就是太阳的距离，
这就好比，
我们用眼睛通过视差计算出来的是，
我们和手指头之间的距离，
而没有办法计算出，
我们的眼睛相对于背景板之间的距离，
那这种方法是怎么算出地球到太阳有多远呢？
没关系，
我们不光能算出太阳有多远，
还能直接解锁整个太阳系所有的距离，
这就是因为我们还有另外一套理论体系可以拿来用，
它就是开普勒行星运动定律，
稍微解释一下，
开普勒的定律是通过长期观测行星的相对运动，
它能告诉我们行星轨道之间的相对比例，
比如说地球的轨道半径是1，
金星大概就是0.72，
火星的轨道半径大概就是1.52，
它就像一张只有比例而没有标齿的地图，
那么刚才说的这个1，
它到底是多少公里，
起初是没有人知道的，
而一旦通过金星零日测出金星和地球的距离，
那我们就能通过带入1和0.72这个比例，
算出来地球和太阳的距离，
以及金星和太阳的距离，
不仅如此，
整张太阳系地图的所有距离，
就都有了单位都能换算成公里了，
这就是我们为什么说，
地球距离太阳1.5公里，
叫做一个天文单位的原因所在了，
所以金星零日加上视差法，
这套方法的意义就在于，
它帮人类确定了太阳系的实际尺度，
当然了，我们这么说起来很轻松，
实际的观测是非常辛苦的，
所有的人站在同一个城市肯定没有用，
视差太小，
所以18世纪的天文学家，
要组织远征队，
有的人去太平洋，
有的人去西伯利亚，
有的人去印度洋，
这么辛苦的拔山射水，
就是为了在准确的时间，
看一下金星零日这个现象，
把它记录下来，
人们坐船出发，
带着非常昂贵的遗弃，
要提前几个月到达，
然后祈祷观测那天天气足够的紧朗，
如果刚好阴天，
那么多年的准备就全都白费了，
观测本身也非常的麻烦，
比如说有黑低效应，
金星靠近太阳系边缘的时候，
小黑点会和边缘出现拉伸和粘连，
就像一滴黑色的液体，
连在边上，
很难判断准确的接触时刻，
这个现象日常也可以观察到，
把你的两个手指头，
靠近你的眼睛，
然后就在你的眼前面，
把两个手指头捏在一起，
你会发现，
在他们真正接触到一起之前，
边缘就会出现拉伸和粘连的状态，
直到后来，
雷达技术出现，
人类可以向金星发射雷达信号，
记录信号的往返时间，
就类似于GPS的原理一样，
距离等于光速乘以往返时间在注意二，
如果往返用了300秒，
总路程就是9000万公里，
单程就是4500万公里，
你发现没有，
这里又回到了前面反复出现的主题，
位置和距离，
经常要靠时间来测，
时间和空间在这个意义上是密不可分的，
航海中用时间测精度，
GPS用信号传播时间来定位，
雷达用电磁波往返时间测行星的位置，
从讲故事的角度，
这一步也发生了关键的变化，
我们人类不再只是测量地球表面，
而是开始把地球本身当作测量的工具，
地球上两个相距很远的观测点，
就像人类的两只眼睛一样，
但是你想，
地球的直径终究是有限的，
你用它当作视差法的机线，
凉太阳系是够用的，
但如果目标是非常远的横行，
视差就会小到几乎测量不出来，
我们人类还需要更大的机线去测量更远的距离，
这个机线就是我们要请出的下一把尺子，
我们现在知道不同的星星距离我们是有缘有尽的，
它们只是投影在同一个方向上，
看起来就像是贴在同一片夜空的画布上一样，
但是在古代这其实并不容易证明，
我们肉眼看星空，
所有的星星就像是定在一个天球上，
相对位置非常地稳定，
你很难判断哪颗在前哪颗在后，
古代人就真的管天空叫做天球，
如果你想测出远近的差别，
就还要靠视差，
但是我们刚才说行星太远了，
用地球直径当机线根本就不够长，
那怎么办呢？
人类想到了另一个办法，
不知道你能不能想到啊？
我们把机线换成了地球的轨道，
地球每年绕太阳一圈，
1月份我们观测一颗恒星，
记录它相对于远处背景恒星的位置，
过了半年，地球跑到了轨道的另一侧，
再观测一次这颗恒星，
两次观测之间，
这个地球就绕了太阳半圈，
所以这两个观测点的位置，
相距大概就是两个天文单位，
大概有3亿公里，
这个就比地球的直径大多了，
相当于我们用1月份的地球当左眼，
用7月份的地球当右眼，
看那颗恒星相对背景位置有没有微小的偏移，
有偏移就能算出距离。
我们取地球的轨道半径，
也就是一个天文单位，
作为三角形的一条边，
从太阳看恒星，
和从地球看恒星，
两条视线之间有一个很小的佳角，
这个角叫做周年视差，
天文学里有一个方便的距离单位，
叫做秒差距，
秒就是一秒两秒的秒，
你刚听到这个秒差距，
可能以为它是一个实践单位，
其实它是一个距离单位，
而且这个距离单位还很大，
视差角是一角秒的恒星，
距离就是一秒差距，
这一秒差距大概就是3.26光年，
我们说的这个角秒有多小呢，
一个圆是360度，
一度分成60个角分，
一个角分再分成60角秒，
所以一角秒就是一度的3600分之一，
这么小的角度差，
它要多精确呢，
给你一个大概的概念，
差不多就是我们隔几公里之外，
看一枚硬币两边的角度差，
宇宙学家观测恒星视差，
通常就是这种量级，
所以你能想象这件事在技术上是非常难的，
思想很简单，
真正测出来，
我们在历史上其实是花了几百年的时间的，
这里还有一段很有意思的历史，
它和日新说的争论纠缠在一起，
我们今天当然知道日新说是对的，
地新说是错的，
但是回到当时，
没有人能飞到天空中去看一看，
到底是太阳绕着地球转，
还是地球绕着太阳转，
我们只能通过一些现象来反推，
如果只看现象的话，
其实地新说也就是太阳围着地球转，
更符合我们观测到的现象，
或者说更符合我们的直觉，
因为毕竟太阳是从东边升起来，
从西边落下去的，
当时地新说和日新说的争论，
也涉及到了视差法，
原理就是，
如果地球真的绕太阳公转，
那么一年中从不同的位置看向恒星，
就应该出现视差，
可是很长的时间里，
谁都观测不到这个视差，
当时反对日新说的人就说，
哎，你看，
如果地球在动，
那恒星的位置应该变化呀，
那现在没有变化，
所以地球没动，
是太阳在动。
说实话，
这个在当时不是说没有道理，
现在你知道问题出在哪里，
问题就在于，
恒星比所有人想象的。
都要远得多得多，
远到,
即使用地球轨道这么大的极限，
视差也小到当时都测不出来，
测不到视差，
不是说明地球没有动，
只是说明仪器还不够精密，
到十九世纪，
贝赛尔测出天鹅做六十一星的视差，
不到一角秒，
刚才我们说了，
就是不到一度的三千六百分之一，
这个是历史上极其重要的结果，
它意味着，
这个星要远到，
用光年来描述，
从那以后，
测量恒星就不是猜测了，
而是进入了定量测量的时代，
当然了，
视差越小，
距离越远，
这个误差影响就越大，
仪器稍微多锁一下，
那好几角秒就出去了，
所以现代天文学会把测量仪送上太空，
我们在地面观测的时候，
星光穿过大气会抖动，
这个就是星星闪烁的原因之一，
对星闪星空的人来说，
星星的闪烁是很美的，
但是对于精密测量来说，
闪烁就是个大麻烦，
卫星在太空中可以避开大气层，
也就避免了这种干扰，
随着卫星的增加，
我们人类测量了大量恒星的空间坐标，
夜空也就从一张球面的星图，
变成了动态的三维结构图，
我们知道哪些恒星近，
哪些恒星远，
哪些属于同一个星团，
哪些曾经从太阳附近经过，
视差法这个方法是非常可靠的，
因为它是纯几合，
只要角度测量的准，
它不依赖恒星是什么类型，
也不需要猜它有多亮，
几合方法是距离测量最基础也最可信的一层，
但是它有个物理上的天花板，
就是恒星越远视差越小，
还是前面的比方，
你把手指头放到眼前，
闭上左眼和右眼，
就能看到手指头位置的变化，
但你看一个很远的东西，
这种方法就不会观察到。
它位置发生了什么变化，
这个就是因为视差变小的原因，
比如说仙女做星系，
距离我们大概有250万公年，
用地球轨道当尺子，
这个视差就会小到没有办法测量，
那到这里，视差法就到头了，
我们人类又要换一把尺子了，
其实我们在地球上，
根本没有办法看到立体的星空的样子，
我们看到的就是一大堆。
大小不同，亮度不同的小亮点，
我们前面说，
在天文学上并不是。
越亮的东西越近，
越远的东西越暗，
一个东西看起来比另外一个东西亮，
有可能是它本身很亮，
也有可能就是因为它离我们近，
这种方法策不准，
主要就是因为我们不知道那颗星星，
它本来是有多亮的，
但是,
如果我们知道一个天体本来有多亮，
再看它现在有多暗，
是不是就能推算它离我们有多远了呢？
因为亮度的衰减，
正比于距离的平方，
这个很好算，
这个思路非常重要，
它就叫做标准逐光，
咱们打个比方，
在一片漆黑的夜晚，
远处有一盏灯，
你看到它挺暗的，
这个有两种可能，
一种本来就是一盏很小很暗的灯，
或者是因为它本来很亮，
但是离你非常远，
所以只看亮不亮，判断不了距离，
但如果你提前知道，
这盏灯就是一盏100瓦的标准灯泡，
事情就变了，
它看起来暗只能是因为远，
光的强度，
我们刚才说，
大概是按照距离的平方反比衰减，
距离变成两倍，
亮度就变成四分之一，
距离变成十倍，
亮度就变成一百分之一，
那么你知道了它真实的亮度，
再测量视觉上的亮度，
就能反推出距离了，
那问题是，
天文学林，
你怎么知道一颗星它本来有多亮呢？
不可能那个星星上刻着说明书，
对吧，我是一颗100瓦的恒星，
这个就引出了一个重要的概念，
叫做造腹变形，
制造的造，
父亲的腹，
变化的变，
造腹变形，
造腹变形它是一类很特殊的变形，
也就是亮度会周期变化的恒星，
它的变化来自于恒星本身周期性的膨胀和收缩，
在一个周期里变亮，变暗，再变亮，再变暗，
这个周期可能是几天，
也可能是几十天，
这种心体非常特殊，
只是会闪还不够，
最关键的是，
造腹变形有一个很重要的规律，
就是,
它的变化周期，
和它真实的亮度是正相关的，
周期越长，
它本身就越亮，
这就是造腹变形的周期和亮度的相关性，
它相当于是给造腹变形贴上了一张标签，
测出一颗造腹变形的变化周期，
就能知道它本身有多亮，
再测它看起来有多亮，
就能知道光线衰减了多少，
就能反算出距离有多远，
这里还有一个必须要提的细节，
那就是，
周期和光度本身的关系也需要校准，
你得知道，
周期十天的造腹变形，
真实的亮度具体是多少嘛，
那这个校准，
要靠更近的，
距离已知的造腹变形，
而他们的距离，
是用我们前面说的视差法测出来的，
你看,
这里就出现了一个非常重要的思想，
距离接T思想，
我们并不是看到更远的地方，
找到一把新的尺子，
就用它来干脆替代掉老的尺子，
不是这样的关系，
你看啊，
我们第一层，
是用视差法测量附近的横行，
第二层，
用这个横行附近的造腹变形，
校准它的周期和光度的关系，
第三层，
用这个关系测量更远星系列的造腹变形，
近处的方法校准远处的方法，
远处的方法再向外扩展，
宇宙侧距，
从来都是这样一层一层搭起来的，
没有一把尺子可以从头两到尾，
这是不是很神奇啊，
宇宙中的坐标，
非常像我们前面说的大地坐标，
也是从几个最原始的点开始，
一点一点的向外扩散，
逐渐形成一张大网的，
另外我还想说说，
造腹变形，
为什么在科学史上有这么重的分量？
因为在20世纪初，
天文学界有一场很大的争论，
就是我们看到夜空中有一些螺旋的星云，
那些模模糊糊的像云彩一样的东西，
它到底是什么呢？
那我站在今天，
当然可以事后诸葛亮地告诉你，
当时人们炒的就是仙女做的星云，
一派的人认为，
它是银河系内部的一些气体云，
另一派认为，
它是银河系之外的其他的星系，
这在当时是非常大的问题，
如果星云只是银河系内部的东西，
那宇宙就很小，
搞不好宇宙就是只有银河系这么大，
那如果他们是银河系之外的导宇宙，
那宇宙就要比我们想象的要大的多，
关键就在于距离，
只要测出仙女做，
这个星云离我们有多远，
就能判断，
它在银河系里面还是外面，
著名的哈伯，
后来就在仙女做星系中发现了造腹变性，
诶，这一下子事情就清楚了，
它用周期和光度关系测出仙女做的距离，
远远超出了当时人们认为的银河系的大小，
结论就是，
仙女做不可能是银河系内部的一团云，
它是另外一个巨大的恒星系统，
里面有几千亿颗恒星，
也就是说，
造腹变性帮助人类确认了，
银河系只是宇宙中无数的星系之一，
这一步你能想象有多重要，
它做的事情已经超出了把某个数字给它算准，
它直接改写了整个宇宙的途径，
不过我们说造腹变性也有它的局限，
它依然可靠，
主要问题就出在亮度上，
当星系特别远的时候，
我们就很难分辨出里面单颗造腹变性的光变了，
更没有办法长期跟踪它的周期，
再加上中间还有星际尘埃捣乱，
尘埃会吸收散射的星光，
那这个计算起来误差就更大了。
当造腹变性不够用了，
人类继续要寻找更加亮的标准的珠光，
那么就邀请我们的下一把尺子，
它是恒星的爆炸。
造腹变性之所以不够用，
我们可以再用一个类笔把它说清楚一点。
当你在夜晚看一座城市，
如果距离足够近，
你能分辨出哪一栋楼，
哪一盏灯在闪，
那个闪瘦的灯就类比于造腹变性，
但如果离得太远，
你就只能看到整座城市是玉团光，
没有办法分辨里面具体的哪一栋楼在闪光了。
那怎么办呢？
如果这个时候城市里突然发生了一次非常亮的爆炸，
亮到可以照亮整座城，
那你在远处也能看到它。
这种爆炸就是1A型超星星，
这里说的1A型超星星的写法呢，
1是罗马数字1，就是一条数线，
A就是一个小写的字母A，
所以它们连到一起，
那个罗马数字1看起来就特别像小写的L，
那L和A连起来就像是拼音拉，
所以民间也有一些叫法管这种超星星叫做拉星超星星，
或者是拉星超星星，
这个没关系，咱们也不用调书带，
你知道说的是一种东西就可以。
超星星是什么呢？
它不是一种星体，
它是恒星死亡或者剧烈爆发的一种极端的事件，
因为它是一场巨大的爆炸，
所以短时间内可以亮到和整个星系相当，
这种现象即便发生在很远的星系里，
我们也能观测得到，
但并不是所有的超星星都能拿来测距，
如果每次爆炸的亮度差异很大，
它就当不了标准珠光，
所以我们需要一类风执亮度有规律，
或者经过较正后可以比较的爆炸，
1A型超星星就正好满足，
这个和白矮星有关系，
白矮星就是类似于太阳的这种恒星，
在生命的晚期留下的非常致命的核心，
它的质量很大，
体积却接近地球，
所以上面的密度特别的高，
而如果一颗白矮星处在双星系统里，
就是有两颗恒星互相绕着转，
那这颗白矮星就可能从它的半星那里不断的把物质吸过来，
质量一点点的增加，
当达到某个邻界状态的时候，
白矮星内部就会发生剧烈的热核失控，
整颗星被炸毁，
释放巨大的能量，
这个就是1A型超星星，
它为什么能侧具有三个原因，
第一就是它非常的亮，
比造富变形要亮得多，
可以在更远的星系中被我们看到，
第二就是它的光谱特征非常的明确，
所谓光谱特征就是我们把天地的光按波长展开，
不同的元素会留下不同的吸收线和发射线，
1A型超星星没有明显的清线就是没有明显的清元素，
而有典型的归吸收特征，
天文学家可以根据这个光谱特征定位到1A型超星星，
第三也是最关键的就是，
它的峰值亮度经过校正之后比较一致，
严格来说就是，
每颗1A型超星星的亮度是有差异的，
但是它们的光变曲线是有规律的，
亮度下降的慢的通常本身就更亮，
亮度下降的快的本身就更暗一些，
通过对这个光变曲线的形状做校正，
就能把它们变成可靠的标准出光，
这个就像我们前面说的造富变形一样，
绝对的亮度是不知道的，
但是可以通过亮度变化的周期来反推绝对亮度，
这个策具的过程也和造富变形很像，
我们先是寻天发现某个星系里突然变亮的新天体，
用光谱确认它是1A型，
记录完整的光变曲线，
根据曲线形状推断绝对亮度，
再和我们实际观测到的亮度比较，
算出亮度衰减的程度，
最后推算出距离。
这两个方法的原理是很相似的，
但是后者能看得远的多，
而1A型超星星的亮度校准，
它又踩在造富变形的肩膀上，
理想情况是找一个比较近的星系，
里面既有造富变形，
又发生过1A型超星星，
先用造富变形测出星系的距离，
再反过来校准这颗超星星的真实亮度，
距离的阶梯就又增加了一层。
视差法校准造富变星，
造富变星校准1A型超星星，
1A型超星星又去测量更远的星系。
每一层都依赖上一层，
这也意味着，
如果低层的校准有误差，
会一路传递到高层。
所以,
现代天文学非常重视系统误差。
尘埃修正的够不够，
不同环境里超星星是不是一致，
望远镜的标准，
还有样本的选择有没有偏差等等等等。
宇宙测距说起来一句话，
就是测亮度算距离。
实际做起来，
是一套非常复杂的数据分析工程。
不过1A型超星星还没有到终点，
我们再往远处走，
问题本身也开始发生了变化。
慢慢的人类不再问，
具体某个星系离我们多远，
而是干脆抛根问题。
宇宙整体到底是怎样的？
宇宙的最远处，
它到底有多远呢？
从这开始，
我们要请出的新的一把尺子，
它测量的对象就是宇宙本身了。
这把尺子的名字叫做红仪。
红仪这个词很多人听过，
它容易被讲得很悬，
我们先从最基础的地方开始说，
光是电磁波，
不同颜色对应不同的波长，
蓝光的波长比较短，
红光的波长比较长。
如果一个天体发出的光，
到达我们这里，
整体波长变长了，
那就是光普线，
像红色的一段移动，
这个就叫做红仪，
反过来，波长变短，
就叫做蓝仪。
红仪最容易理解的一种原因是多不乐效应，
我们说声音也有类似的现象，
因为声音也是波嘛，
当一辆救护车向你使过来的时候，
紧敌的音调逐渐的变高，
离你远去的时候，
音调会逐渐的变低，
声波就是因为一个东西，
向你而来或者离你而去，
被压缩或者拉长了，
光也一样，
发光的天体远离我们，
光波就会被拉长，
看起来就是红仪，
如果一个发光的天体靠近我们，
它就会发生蓝仪。
当天文学家测量星系的光普，
发现大量星系的光都红仪的时候，
人们就自然地提出一个解释，
这些星系都在远离我们。
的事情还不只是这样。
20世纪初，
天文学家还发现了一个重要的规律，
那就是越远的星系，
红仪就会越大，
也就是离我们越远的星系，
退行的速度，
离我们远去的速度就越大。
这个就是哈伯定律的核心，
可以简单的写成，
退行速度等于哈伯常数乘以距离。
测出一个星系的红仪，
就能估算它退行的速度，
再结合哈伯常数就能估算出距离。
这里我们要特别强调一点，
实际上在以前的节目里讲过不止一次，
就是很多人会误解遥远星系的红仪，
并不是说他们在普通的空间里，
非离我们。
更准确的说，
星系几乎都是静止在他们本地的空间的，
是宇宙空间本身在膨胀。
星系类似于嵌在空间中，
随着空间膨胀，
星系之间的距离变大。
光在膨胀的空间中传播的时候，
波长也被一起拉长，
也就是红仪了。
经常被人举的例子就是一个气球，
气球上均匀的画着很多的点，
每个点之间的距离都差不多，
我们就在其中的一个点上。
当气球被吹开的时候，
那些原本距离我们很近的点，
离开我们的速度没有那么快，
而越是距离我们遥远的点，
因为我们和他们之间的空间更大，
也就是这个气球上的皮更多，
那么空间膨胀，
也就是气球被吹开的效应，
就会更明显。
实际的结果就是，
越远的星系，
红仪越严重。
那红仪怎么测呢？
这个问题也不是特别好理解，
我们来说一下，
你想,
红仪红仪，
意思是一个本来不太红的光变得更红了，
那咱们得先知道，
这个光它本来是什么颜色才行，
不然你怎么知道它变红了呢？
那这个本来的颜色，
我们怎么能知道呢？
诶,
这就要说到一个非常巧妙的方法了，
天文学家靠的是光谱，
我们前面稍微提了一嘴，
这里给你讲清楚，
什么是光谱呢？
你可以把一束光想象成有很多不同颜色，
不同波长，
混合在一起的，
就像阳光，
我们通过三棱镜，
会分解成彩虹光一样，
天文学家用仪器，
把星系发出的光也可以分解开来，
就得到一条，
从紫色到红色的光带，
关键来了，
在这条光带上并不是均匀而连续的，
而是会出现一些特殊的暗线，
或者亮线，
这些线叫做普线，
那为什么会有这些线呢？
因为那些星系里不同的元素，
在发光或者吸收光的时候，
只会在特定的波长上产生作用，
比如说青元素，
它总是会在某几个固定的波长上产生吸收线，
干元素也有自己的特定波长，
那元素也一样，
我们在日常的生活中看不同的元素，
燃烧的火焰颜色也不一样，
就是类似这个原理啊，
这个就像每个元素都有自己的指纹一样，
无论这个青元子在地球的实验室里，
还是在几十亿光年外的星系里，
它产生的普线的相对位置都是一样的，
比如说三明两暗，
接上五明八暗，
这么一个光谱。
这些普线的相对位置，
跟它们距离我们的远近是完全没有关系的，
是由原子的物理性质决定的。
所以天文学家做的事情就是这样的。
第一步，
我们在地球上的实验室里，
已经非常清楚的知道，
青的普线应该出现在哪个波长上，
比如说在656.3nm这个位置，
这个就是我们的标准答案。
第二步，
我们用望远镜去观测一个遥远的星系，
把它的光分解成光谱，
我们在光谱里也找到了青的普线。
第三步就是关键了，
我们发现这条青的普线，
它每条线之间的相对位置是一样的，
但是整体的位置，
并没有出现在656.3nm这个位置上，
而是出现在了720nm的位置上。
你看普线的形状没有变，
它是整体向更长的波长移动了，
也就是像红色那一段移动了。
这就是为什么天文学家可以测红一的原因，
它们不是在比较颜色的深浅，
而是在比较普线的位置。
因为我们知道这条线本来应该在656.3nm，
现在却在720nm，
所以我们就能算出它移动了具体多少。
用这个移动的量，
除以原来的波长，
就得到了红一辆，
一般我们把它叫做G。
G等于0.1,
大概意思就是波长拉长了10%，
G等于1的意思就是波长变成了原来的两倍。
测出红一，
我们就能拿到两个信息。
第一,
它就会告诉我们这个天体处在宇宙膨胀中的什么位置，
前面我们说了近处的红一小，
远处的红一大。
第二,
它告诉我们这束光来自多早以前的宇宙，
因为光速有限，
一个遥远星期的光可能走了几十一年，
才来到我们这儿。
我们看到的也不是它现在的样子，
而是它很久以前的样子。
这点也很重要，
当我们看向远方，
其实就是看向过去，
红一即是距离指标，
它同时又回到了时间指标。
前面的尺子，
我们大多是在空间里测距离，
红一这把尺子，
开始把时间又放进来了。
当你测量一个高红一星期的时候，
你其实是在问，
这是光发出的时候，
宇宙有多年轻呢？
从那个时候到现在，
空间又膨胀了多少呢？
顺便说一句，
在宇宙的尺度上，
距离已经和光传播的时间，
宇宙膨胀，
观测方式等等，
纠缠在一起了。
那么,
因为很远地方的星星发出来的光，
来到我们这里，
用的时间是如此之长，
以至于，
这些光发出来的时间，
可能是宇宙刚刚形成的时间，
所以越往宇宙深处走，
测距越不像普通的测量，
越像是在重建宇宙的历史。
另外就是，
每次我说到红仪，
都必须跟一个解释，
否则就一定会有小伙伴来问。
很多人对红仪有一个常见的误解，
就是,
如果所有远方的星星都在远离我们，
是不是说明我们恰好在宇宙的中心呢？
答案当然是不。
在均匀膨胀的宇宙里，
每个地方的观测者都会看到，
远处所有的星星远离自己。
还是刚才我们说的那个吹气球的例子，
每个点都能看到其他的点越来越远，
而且越远的点远离越快，
但是没有哪个点是地球表面的中心。
当然，气球的表面是一个二维的曲面，
而宇宙是一个三维的曲面，
这个没有关系，只是帮助你理解。
重点是，
宇宙膨胀并不是所有星星都从我们这炸出去，
是空间尺度在整体的变大。
我们之前专门就有几期节目讲空间膨胀的事，
你可以回去翻一翻听一听。
不过我们说的宏宜策剧还要有一个前提，
就是你得知道宇宙是怎么膨胀的。
换句话说，
就是我们要知道宇宙加速膨胀的速度和宏宜之间的数学关系，
也就是需要一个宇宙学模型。
在很远的地方，
膨胀受到物质密度，
受到暗能量，
受到空间曲率的影响，
所以宏宜本身也是需要被教准的。
怎么教准呢？
聪明的你肯定已经猜出来了，
还是靠距离阶梯。
视差法叫准造幅变星，
造幅变星叫准1A型超星星，
1A型超星星测出一批星系的距离，
再比较这些距离和宏宜，
建立起宏宜和距离的关系。
前面的每一把尺子都在为后面的尺子服务。
而到了宏宜这个尺度，
我们人类第一次系统性地看到，
整个宇宙它在膨胀这样一个途径，
遥远星系的光，
带着膨胀的历史信息，
来到了我们这里。
所以我们可以说，
前面的方法都是在测量某个具体的对象，
一根杆的影子，
一艘船的位置，
一颗恒星，
一次爆炸。
而如果我们再往远处看，
其实就不是在看具体的星体了。
接下来我们人类在测量的，
就是整个宇宙的膨胀历史。
人类的探索其实还远远没有结束，
宇宙学家现在也会使用一些更新的工具，
作为更大尺度的测量尺和标准珠光，
比如说CMB宇宙微波背景辐射，
比如说BAO重子生学震荡，
还有以前人们很陌生，
但现在大家都逐渐了解的引力波。
这些尺子一方面还在探索中，
另外一方面呢，
就是他们确实是太过于技术流，
本来我这期的节目里是准备展开讲的，
但是思来想去还是把他们砍掉了。
我们普通人了解人类测量宇宙的尺子，
就到红一这一把，
其实就够了。
我们从身边最小，
也最直观的距离开始测量，
一路向更远的距离，
直到我们去测量宇宙的尽头。
现在你回看这一整条线，
就会发现人类的尺子一直在变。
可以说人类浆量世界的方式，
这件事到今天，
已经和我们直觉上的那种浆量完全不同了。
我们根本不是在物理空间中。
拉一条看得见的尺子，
我们其实是在读各种信号，
影则的角度，中表的时间，
还有三角形的角度，
光的亮度，光谱的红仪等等等等，
每一种信号都是宇宙给我们的测量线索，
而科学做的事情，
就是把这些线索变成数字，
再变成我们人类能理解的模型，
最后变成一张越来越大的地图。
聊到最后，
我想跟你分享一个很奇妙的感受，
我们这一期一直在讲浆量世界，
但是浆量世界这件事，
最奇妙的地方就在于，
人类其实从来没有站在世界之外。
我们没有站在地球外面，
先看清楚地球长什么样，
再回头画地图。
我们也没有站在太阳系外面，
看清太阳地球金星之间的距离，
再把它们标出来。
我们更不可能站在宇宙的外面，
像看一个模型一样，
直接看到宇宙的大小，
形状和演化，
我们一直在系统的内部。
我们在地球的表面，
站在一小块路地上，
一艘船上，
站在一台望远镜的后面，
站在一个非常局部，
非常有限的位置上。
这个就是我们人类认知世界的基本处境，
我们没有上帝视角，
没有全景图，
我们得到的永远是局部的信息。
这些东西都很有限，
甚至说很不起眼。
如果你不去追问的话，
那影子只是影子，
星光也只是星光。
但是科学真正厉害的地方就在于，
它不要求我们一开始就拥有全部答案。
它做的是另外一件事，
那就是在有限的观察里，
找出可靠的关系。
只要这个关系足够稳定，
足够可验证，
能够和其他的事实互相的印证，
人类就能把我们对世界的理解，
一点一点的向外推。
从一个角度推到一段胡长，
从一个时间差推到一条惊险，
从一个视差角推到恒星的距离，
从一个光遍的周期推到星系的尺度，
最后再从一条普线的偏移，
推到宇宙的膨胀。
它们之间是互相依靠，
互相印证的。
这背后就是一件非常朴素的事情，
我们测量，我们校准，
我们比较修正，
再测量，再校准，再比较。
科学并不总是像电影里演的那样，
有人灵光一现，
世界的真相一下子就展开在所有人的面前。
更多的时候它非常慢，
一代人测出一个小小的角度，
下一代人再去改进一台机器，
一代人积累一批数据，
一代人发现一个偏差，
再有一代人发现这个偏差并不是错误，
它的背后是一个全新的事情。
科学给了我们人类一种很特殊的能力，
就是在没有全局视角的情况下，
仍然有勇气去建立关于整体的知识。
我觉得这是我们这期节目最想表达的东西。
我们很小，这点我们不用回避，
和地球相比我们很小，
和太阳系相比地球很小，
更不要说在可观测的宇宙里，
我们的太阳系和银河系。
也只是小小的一个亮点。
这就是科学很动人的地方，
它从来不把人类抬高成宇宙的中心，
恰恰相反，它一次又一次的告诉我们，
你不在中心，地球不在中心，
太阳系，银河系也不在中心，
但没有关系，即使不在中心，
你仍然可以去理解。
我觉得这是一种更成熟的自信。
所以，当你下次打开手机地图，
看到那个蓝色的小箭头的时候，
你可以稍微多想一秒，
它看起来只是一个小小的点，
但它背后连接着经纬度，
地球模型，卫星，原子钟，
相对论等等等等知识，
还有我们人类几百年上千年的测量史。
当你下次抬头看星星的时候，
你也可以再多想一秒，
那一点点星光，
可能已经走了几十年，
几百万年甚至更久，
它带着大量的信息，
比如距离，时间，运动，元素，
还有宇宙膨胀等等信息，
来到你的面前，让你看上眼。
而我们这个种族中，
有那么一些人要做的，
就是学会读懂这些信息。
这就是我们人类浇量世界的方式。